ما زالت عمليات الانقاذ مستمره يعني
المسؤولون في مؤسسات الطوارئ
والمتطوعين يعملون باستمرار لانتشال او
انقاذ مزيد من العالقين داخل القرى التي
قد غرقت بالكامل وغمرتها المياه كما ان
الكهرباء مقطوعه وسائل الاتصال شبكات
الاتصال كلها الهاتف لا توجد اي من مظاهر
الحياه والتكنولوجيا في تلك المنطقه اثر
فيضانات نهر الدنيا برو رغم ذلك يعني
الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره في نفس المنطقه
وحولها ذلك ما يعني تسبب بعدم عوده او
السرعه بعوده الكهرباء والحياه الى
المنطقه تعمل وزاره الطوائر الروسيه على
ضخ مزيد من المياه سحبها وارسالها الى
المناطق التي يمكن ان تستخدم للري او اكثر
في المدن التي
لكن ليس بشكل كامل يعني لانقاذ الناس
الذين ما زالوا يعيشون في بيوتهم في وسط
المدينه لكن يعني القائم باعمال رئاسه
المقاطعه فلاديمير سالدو قال بان الجيش
الاوكراني قصف مراكز
اللاجئين الذين تم انقاذهم من هذه الكارثه
واسفر هذا القصف عن قتل امراه واعداد من
الاصابات بالفعل هنا في زبروج حيث نحن
الاعمال العسكريه مستمره الهجومات
الاوكرانيه المضاده تنتشر ما حول زبروجي
وصولا الى دانيت حيث حول مدينه باخمه
مساله مهمه ان القوات الاوكرانيه دخلت الى
بلده كليشيفكا وتحاول التقدم اكثر من
الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه من منطقه باقمت
في ذات الوقت الذي يحاول فيه الجيش الروسي
صد كل الهجومات المضاده الاوكرانيه في كل
المحاور ان كان محور مارينكا
فلاديم او الضيفكا مناطق كثيره واعداد
القذائف التي سقطت على مقاطعه اكثر من مئه
اسفرا هذا القصف عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
بينهم طفل الاعمال العسكريه مستمره هجومات
مضاده
جزيره القرم كما اسلفته المعطيات العسكريه
على الارض حول محيط دونيات يوحي بالفعل
ببدء الهجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا هناك
بالفعل الهجوم المضاد قد بدا ليله امس
كانت صاخبه هنا في زاباروج اطراف زبرجه
عند بلده اريخافا
بالفعل كان هجوم اوكراني كبير جدا
يعني الجهات العسكريه هنا اكدت بانها صدت
هذا الهجوم
وهناك هدوء نسبه في ساعات الصباح الباكر
تشير السلطات هنا الى ان هذا الهدوء بسبب
حشد الجيش الاوكراني لمزيد من الجنود من
اجل اكمال العمليات العسكريه في هذا
الهجوم المضاد يعني نكرر بان بان او نؤكد
بان جميع المحاور تشهد هجومات اوكرانيه
مضاده والجيش الروسي يعمل
بعمليات عسكريه دفاعيه من خلال الخنادق
والقصف بالاله العسكريه الثقيله من اجل
ايقاف تمدد القوات الاوكرانيه وعودتها الى
المناطق التي سيطر عليها
الجيش الروسي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات